Hello everyone. Welcome to the
toxic Google. I'm Kevin Volcan.
Today we had the creative team behind
the documentary back kid begins.
And so we'd like to welcome Mike Do
Tan who played the penguin in the film.
Patricia Wilson,
CEO of the Greater Bay area.
Make a wish and Dana knock men who uh,
directed the documentary film.
So thank you guys so much for being here,
having us. So Patricia,
we'll start with you.
Just can you tell us how you turn San
Francisco into Gotham for miles? No.
Okay.
It's going to be talking over Great Mike.
It's like,
so,
so, um, initially when I
began the wish, um, uh,
if you haven't seen the documentary
you'll, you'll discover in the film,
his wish was to be the real Batman and
he was five at the time and battling
leukemia. So game on, right? What
does that mean to be the Real Batman?
And so when we have a
wish type that's creative,
you get yourself creatively in the eyes
of the child and try to find out who was
Batman to him,
what's that look like?
And we did a series of interviews with
his volunteer wish granters and his
parents. And we, I offered,
I like to offer choices because then I
know if I offer this and that that maybe
they can get, you know,
and I offered to, you know,
maybe we could do a caper to school and
we could kidnap his principal or you
know, or maybe he's the bad
guy. You ended up ending.
Now he feels about the
principal or you know,
I offered we could do something at six
flags and rescue someone on a roller
coaster. Or I offered, you know,
I was driving home one night, um,
I live and work in the city and the fog
was rolling in and I thought, you know,
it was pretty cool.
This could be Gotham city.
It's kind of more Gotham
than New York in many ways.
And so I offered a very bold statement.
I could turn San Francisco into Gotham
city. And that was the one that resonated.
And I began doing it on a five year
old scale thinking, you know, why can,
you know, a cable car,
it'll be a little corner.
But it just got bigger and bigger based
on the number of people who wanted to be
involved in it ended up being
on a scale for grownups and uh,
he was oblivious to that.
So it was one of my favorite things is
that he's still got his five year old
version that we were very protective
of him. Um, but beyond that, um,
there were a whole lot of people, 25,000,
over 25,000 showed up personally and,
or for 2 billion impressions worldwide.
Right.
And so what do you think attributed
to that? Cause that it was just,
it was such a huge global event.
I know Mike has started with your
tweet that went out that was just like,
you,
here's what's going on and all of
a sudden it just exploded. So yeah,
I knew spending this much time on
the Internet would finally pay off.
It's a little plug for
you guys. Yeah, it's,
you know, it, it just was, I
do some volunteer things and,
and make a wish was something that
I chosen to do this year. And, um,
Eja the guy who played Batman,
it had pulled me into this magic
and it was very small at the time,
but it was starting to get bigger and
bigger. And I thought, oh, this is great.
And I write a blog and I, I, you know,
I'm on Facebook and Twitter everything
too much and Google plus, sorry. Um,
and yeah, all of the things.
And uh, and I thought, well,
I'll post some photos of just
what's happening and, um,
people that are interested,
we'll get to see it and,
and maybe that will help inspire other
folks to do some more volunteering.
Cause you know, I'm taking the day off
work and running around the ballpark, um,
dressed up as a bad guy. It's pretty fun.
And that was like one of the rehearsals.
And from there, that's where I'm
apparently so says the, um, research,
I guess on this, that from that post it
started to then just snowball like crazy.
And people really liked
the idea of it and,
and just were kind of racing
to be involved themselves.
And you know, it was interesting.
We were sort of, um, uh,
a psychologist from Philadelphia who,
whom Dana interviewed, who flew out to,
to study why so many people were drawn
like a magnet to this event. And I,
she and I have spoken since a couple
of times and I do think that right now,
and this digital age,
I think there's a level of fatigue.
People are tired of the
sensational and bad news and,
and feeling a little overwhelmed.
And it was right after the sequester was
right after. So I think, I think they're,
they're tired of covering people who are
famous for being famous and, and, um,
so I think it was ripe for a good story
and it was exciting to think that social
media became social good. Um, so
that part is really interesting too,
that people who spoke,
I mean a couple of the,
under the two most important
themes that happen, um,
in the tweets that were measured,
first of all,
I had a 97% positive rate and
tweets, which is unheard of, right?
It's never happened before.
Um, and all of that,
some of that was sparring with a penguin
because of the penguin, how to handle
oh yeah. And My tweets were evil, right?
The two messages were,
yeah.
Um,
it renewed people's faith in humankind.
And the other message was that people
felt it was the best thing that ever
happened to San Francisco.
And that can make me cry to the state
because if you had told me that I'd be
involved in a project that
could reach that magnitude,
I would have never believed you.
Um, but it was that kind of day.
It's the kind of day I saw a news
report. Someone reviewed, um,
the documentary and said,
you know,
it was the kind of news event that
people remember where they were that day.
And they'll tell me, oh, I was an
la following the story I remember.
And that's just insane to think that we
were part of something that made people
so happy.
So it's delightful.
It's one of the only one in the very
few documentaries that I could actually
name that is actually a positive
message because usually they're just so
depressing ad. So, you know, like it
just, it's, this is just a really,
really feel good. So, Dana, can I want to
get into that where it's just, you know,
well, but it was great because it was
definitely a breath of fresh air. But,
so what, so what brought you to the
product because you came in after the day,
but did you know what was going
on during the day and what was,
that's always my most embarrassing
question. I missed the entire thing.
Like I feel like I was not one of
the 2 billion people who followed.
It's just so embarrassing. I
think I, I was editing that day,
another project. I was really
immersed in that. And yeah, I was, um,
I guess just kind of zoned in that
day. But, um, I had done three very,
very harsh down trodden,
um,
difficult but important
documentaries before. That's
when I was finishing up one.
I'm on toxic chemicals and all of our
products and the lack of regulation.
I watched them. No, and it's true and
that's it. But it's why I wanted to,
I was looking for something more positive.
Or you watched him. Oh, good, good. Um,
and so I was,
so I was looking for something lighter.
Um,
I was looking for something more
childlike. I have three little kids.
I was looking for something that
I can engage with them on. Um,
so I was looking for something
just right when this happened.
And so I learned about it
the day after, um, when, uh,
a bunch of people I was
on a conference call with,
we're talking about it and they were all
men and they were all kind of in their
forties,
and they were all talking to this little
boy in this Cape and running around San
Francisco. And I googled it and I was
like, oh my gosh, what an amazing thing.
This is perfect. Too Bad. I missed it.
The lucky person who is doing
that documentary, um, you
know, God bless them. And,
and then, um, we, my producer Lisa
and I got a call with make-a-wish, um,
and they're like, Oh yeah,
come in tomorrow morning.
And turned out people had
had reached out to them,
but they were so inundated with this
thing blowing up and going viral that they
couldn't deal with a
documentary team at the time.
But we had the good fortune of finding
out we were going to do it regardless of
what it took,
whether we had to crowd source all
the video or whatever we had to do.
But at the end of this two and a half
hour meeting where we first met and became
great friends and launch this project,
I said, you didn't have to shoot it,
did you? She's like, Oh yeah, we wanted
to have a fundraising video for our gala.
So we shot it with five cameras.
And so that really made it a heck
of a lot easier for my editor, for,
for all of us. And then we kind
of filled in the blanks with, um,
with the interviews and finding
all the different people,
like the woman Susan from Philadelphia
and others who had flown in for this and
just a myriad of other
people who made it happen.
Was that a difficult
process though of taking,
getting all that footage and trying to
make a cohesive story out of it? No,
it was such a funny thing.
I mean maybe Kurt,
my awesome friend and editor
and co-writer would disagree,
but I mean we had the layout
for the movie right away.
I mean I applied for a grant very early
on and the nuts and bolts of the film
stayed the same from the beginning.
So there,
I think this was easier in a way
because the story was so laid out.
I mean it was a chronology.
I mean we knew we wanted
to have his backstory in
animation, so it was less sad,
more kid like get it over with the sad
part in the first 10 minutes of the movie.
And then from there have the rest of the
first act of meeting all the people, um,
and then call the beginning of
the second act would be when,
when Mike's blog went viral.
So that kind of launches the whole
viral nature of the whole thing.
And they're kind of like now, oh no, this
is that. We thought it was one thing.
Now it's another thing that was a second
act and then the third act was the day
of. And so that kind of came to me
very quickly and the structure of it.
So really it was just filling in all
the pieces and all the cameras that day
really followed. So we
knew the capers, you know,
we had all the papers laid out and so
it was actually pretty seamless. I mean,
the hardest thing it was that I promised
Patricia we would have a cut on the one
year anniversary of it and
I had never made a film.
I'm in less than three to four years and
so this was going to be about 10 months.
So it was like, oh shit. I didn't know how
long it took. You know, and when anybody,
anybody applies for a job, they say, oh,
the person wants. And they're like, oh,
she wants it. And nine months, yeah,
I can do that. How many hours was it?
The curt wanted to watch all the footage.
Okay. Yeah, he, that was the one thing.
So curt,
I had two editors fall through on and
that was a source of a lot of stress for
me just because I had it all written.
Um,
and got it in a place that I could give
it to an editor and I didn't have an
editor.
And so then a really talented friend of
mine who's a director in his own right,
he,
I didn't know he would take on somebody
else's project and he needed work at the
very moment that I needed an editor.
So he took it on and I had it laid out.
And so I was like,
hoping that he would just start editing
right away and he's like, no, no, no.
I have to watch every frame of it. And
I was like, every frame of it. I mean,
it was something like Tor
terabytes. I mean Mike was just, uh,
it just goes on and on and on.
I was watching, I was like,
why won't I stop talking?
Stop. No, and so I'm, so,
he insisted on watching every moment
of it, but it was such the right move.
Cause he, he found things that I
hadn't had time yet to even find,
which were little nuggets between miles
and Ega, the bad kid or the Batman.
And it was a really the right move. But
he, I mean, I think he spent a month,
it was about, I think at that point
about three terabytes worth of footage.
And it wasn't four K so it was, it was,
um, a lot of footage. That's crazy. So,
and so Patricia, so from the initial time
when the wish came in from, you know,
November 15th, there was, and so when, um,
like how long was that between
when the initial wish game?
So I got the wish, uh, end of January,
early February in my program director
walked in and we'd worked together many
years and she said, I have your Christmas
present. I have a superhero wishing.
And I'd always wanted,
thought it would be fun.
And I thought it would be that our,
our network of volunteers and fun and
wild and crazy people would really get
behind it. And we could do a really
cool creative wish like that.
So that was always, I'd see other
chapters to it and think, Oh man,
San Francisco wouldn't we love
costumes? Right. So I think we could,
we could do a good job.
So I had the benefit of time to planet it.
Partly the family didn't want to do it
any sooner than November because he had
his surgery to have his port removed,
which is how we got as chemotherapy.
So they wanted it to be
after his chemotherapy,
so he'd have energy to be a superhero.
And it was after farming season, um,
his dad's a farmer and I'm also a
volunteer fireman and mom's a nurse.
And so they're just kind of this
quintessential live on a farm. Adorable.
Tiny little too late. Oh, beautiful.
And so this is in the film, it's
just, it's gorgeous. Yeah. Yup. Yup.
And so, um, I began, you know,
initially doing the work to understand
the creativity part and who Batman was.
Um, and then early on,
because they, he was shy.
We weren't sure how that
was going to work. I,
I suggested to the family that he'd be a
mini me and I have a full sized Batman.
And Eja was my first choice because
I'd worked with him 10 years prior on a
project in which he created a video
game that fights cancer cells. Um, yeah,
Ben's game. Uh, and so
I knew he'd be amazing,
partly because he's a former stunt double
and he's a, an acrobat. And I needed,
they said, you know, there were more
interested in gadgets, not the villain,
so we didn't want really scary villains.
Um,
so we began putting it
all together around that.
And the first thing that came to mind
was a cable car rescue on Nob Hill. Like,
why not?
Right.
And then the rest kind of fell into place
because miles was a huge giants fan.
So we wanted to involve something
with a ballpark. And um,
it's still kind of crazy to think,
you know,
you and I've talked a fair amount since
then. Then we both had true confessions.
Wine might've been involved, I
don't know, but true confession
and Scott, both of us literally Google
post traumatic stress disorder. Yeah.
Yeah. Because of this experience.
And you know, it's so pleasant,
it's wonderful. But it's
also really scary. Yeah.
To be the center of a story that was one
of the biggest news stories of the year.
And I'll tell you it just desperate to
do a good job. A very personal story.
So I was online dating during
that time. Yeah. And uh,
I didn't think to take my profile
down. Hmm. And so when I log,
wow. Wow, that was delete,
delete, block block.
And then it was funny be busy
till November 15th. Well it was,
it wasn't until I,
you Ari,
I logged back on it and there where I
want to be your superhero going. Oh Wow.
Right. I to marriage or utility bill
for you. What was that? Oh my God,
it was blocked. Delete. And you know,
when people take my image and put it in
Google images and figure out who I was,
right. So I began immediately saying, oh,
a children's charity executive.
I started not,
and it was like I was in the witness
protection burger when I sit next to
someone on a plane. Now, I
won't tell them. Look, I do.
So we're in to film them.
Yeah.
They're involved with Jude. So, and
like, so you got burned by [inaudible].
So can you talk about just,
she'd mentioned, you know,
with not carrying these scary characters,
so you were,
penguin was the very iconic
one from like the 60 series.
Can you talk about that kind
of development and we're
working with miles or EGID
kind of make sure that it wasn't
scary and sure, sure, sure.
Yeah. So not being an active at
all. Like I'm a software engineer,
like everybody else here, everybody, um,
to some extent anyway, I'm
sure. Um, so, you know,
this is by far not what I do for a living.
Um,
I'm obviously one of the, like, I'm
sure Google has the exact percentages,
but I'm one of the say 4% extroverted
computer scientists in the world. Um,
so we're a rare breed, but still
nonetheless not an actor by any means.
And so I just really wanted to make
sure that it did a good job. And,
um, you know, my girlfriend
really? Ooh, now fiance,
um, she's going to love that
part. Um, uh, my fiance,
so my girlfriend at the
time, uh, she said, you know,
she really kept me grounded with
the whole thing and said, you know,
this isn't like as it started getting
bigger and bigger and bigger, I was like,
oh my God. Like all these people are
coming, they have all these expectations,
they want to have fun,
they want to see this like fun,
silly caper thing and you know,
how am I going to make sure
that they enjoy themselves?
How am I going to make sure that I as
a first time volunteer for make-a-wish,
it's a hell of a one to start with.
Um,
how am I going to make sure
that I represent make-a-wish
and the best way that I
can in the way that they want me to
represent them to this globe. Now,
global audience, unexpectedly
global audience. So you know, I,
and everybody else involved in the project
also were very concerned about doing
that and doing the best
possible job we could.
So I kind of reverted back
to my sort of engineering,
my sort of, you might
say meticulous, I guess,
obsessive engineering background and
just kind of researching as much as I
could. I was like, okay. So I watched
all the old Batman's when I was a kid,
so I'll rewatch them. I was like,
oh, thank God it's on Netflix.
And so it was maybe two weeks out and
I started having a panic attack that,
that I, you know, I didn't
know the character and I
wasn't going to do a good job.
I don't even know what his walk
is like. And so I watched, um,
as many as I could find quickly. And, uh,
the 1967 movie, I believe it is a 68, um,
I watched that like five times just over
and over and rewind just the penguin
parts and be like, okay,
so that's why you kind of,
you've gotten this sorta like kinda
leans into it and he's squinting his eyes
all the time and he kind of,
there's like a few,
like really silly kind of things like,
uh, like puns that he'd throw in there.
And it was all hilarious and ridiculous.
Um,
and of course we decided to base it off
the old characters because that's what
miles liked. And also, um, as much
as I love the Danny Devito Penguin,
yeah, that's not going to work for
a five year old. Um, it's, you know,
it's still gives me
nightmares. So, so, uh, yeah,
so I just, I just watched a lot of it, a
lot, a lot and practice the walk. And, um,
once we got the costumes from the, that
was like a week out, we got the costumes.
So I hadn't even seen what it was gonna
look like yet. You know, I tried that on,
I wore the Monaco all the weekend before.
I just kind of wore it the whole time.
I was like, oh, okay,
the penguin is doing the sneer cause
you have to to keep the monocle in.
It's like part of the costume.
I had no idea. Um, so yeah,
I practiced a lot with them on the
club's doing this for awhile because it's
kind of hard to keep those things
in. Um, but uh, yeah, it was great.
So just kind of a lot of just sort
of effort and energy into trying to
understand what I was doing and see
examples of very excellent people are just
Meredith in this case, doing
that thing in the past. Um,
and sort of getting my
own twist a little but,
but really kind of researching the best
way and then ultimately remembering what
my girlfriend said was,
remember an Ega said this,
which was everybody was on the same page.
This is all for miles in the end.
30,000 people are going
to come and watch this.
Every news agency in the world is going
to be there like burning through photos.
Google's likeyes is going to put
you in the video. Thanks for that.
That was awesome.
Um,
but ultimately this is about
miles achieving as well.
And those other 30,000 people might be
disappointed and that wasn't our job.
Yeah.
The job is to make sure miles has a
great time and that's all that counts.
So that kind of takes the pressure
off the fact that BBC is like,
so what do you think?
Yeah.
Remember when we were rehearsing?
Yeah. And you and, and Emj.
We're in the Ballpark,
right?
So we're doing rehearsal and it was
Mike's first time that he's hearing the
whole row we're on through.
So we're sitting there giving
you a run through going, okay,
so the fire boats are going to be over
here and it's like fireball, fireball?
And I said,
yeah.
And I know that they're trying to get
to have a plane pull with a Hashtag.
It's like there's going to play no,
actually their story and
it's all because of all,
and this is where the helicopters are
coming in. I was like, what is going on?
And and it was that day and we were
doing being goofy. And I thought,
wouldn't it be cool if I was able to
figure out to do a handle for penguin and
have penguin tweeting that day and had
the idea and then quickly managed to say
this. That's insane, Patricia.
That'll never happen.
But then literally the next day Twitter
called me and said, do you want help?
And I said, Oh hell yes. Yes.
And I have this crazy idea and I've always
wanted to tweet a wish in real time.
And this was a public wished so it was
okay. And they said we're on board.
And initially they had four
people at the end of the day,
they had 12 people managing our Twitter
feed. Yeah, it was crazy. It was,
how are you showing the film? Just
the buildup to it. So, you know,
you have 10 months to plant where,
you know,
11 months to plan this thing and then
all of a sudden the final month this
explode. So can you talk about
that time of an exploding in the,
how did you manage that?
Your heart is beating faster,
I know where you didn't
feel the tension to be like,
so thanks to his Facebook posts
that he literally cut and paste, um,
the schedule for the day. Like this
looks great problem, tears all the time.
He goes, this is the coolest wish
ever. And then a blogger of silicon up.
So FFS February or November 8th or ninth,
I forget which day now. Um, posted it
and we saw how everybody, you know,
and I had people tagging Facebook and
private messaging me and going to tune you
know about this. Like yes, I do
hold on it since January. And,
and mind you,
we're doing 380 wishes this year,
so we're working on lots
of wishes. Right. Um,
and so that kind of happens on the weekend
comes and goes and I see it mentioned
a few times and then on Monday it gets
another blogger and then by Wednesday the
traditional press started coming,
which I find interesting.
That traditional press covers
whatever happens, social media. Um,
so we decided what it's going to
be news and then they cover it.
And so then it was kind of like,
and you know,
so first it was local news and then we
started getting national news and then
we've got international news and then
we've got Al Jazeera and the good year
blimp called. And I think the joke
internally, I mean we were law,
I will see like who else is going to
call it, what are we going to have next?
The president.
And then he
tweeted out a a beautiful message.
Yeah,
it was incredible.
Incredible.
So can you guys talk about just that
one handling that sort of big event and
Dana and just Kinda your,
you know,
just the handling of the movie with
the family and miles, cause I'm,
I'm guessing like once it blows up,
it was like, oh this isn't right.
Exactly. Well and you can't control
that. Right? So it wasn't, um,
I gave the family again, choices and I
said, look, um, this thing has blown up.
We've never had this happen before. My
instincts are, I think it'll be good,
but it may not be what miles want,
so we can change the date and I can
go private and do something completely
different.
We can keep the date,
just change the locations where
we can stay steady in the course.
And they talked about it and they chose
to study the course because they had so
many family who were coming in and they
had scheduled this for so long and they
said, we think it'll be good. And
they weren't really big. You know,
the beauty was he's on Twitter, he's
five. So none of it was spoiled for him.
But, um, you know, I got,
so I think the first opportunity to see
the chief of police after that was a,
a couple of weeks later and both of
us were confessing to each other the
concerns we had. I mean him for
public safety and, and me to, to go,
would this make, make a
wish, look bad ball, make San
Francisco look bad. You know,
what could go wrong. Um, I do, I really,
really regret though that I didn't have
miles really rob a bank because I think
we would've gotten away with it and
I'd never need to fundraise for,
make a wish again. Banks could
have been competing know Rodney.
But, uh, it was, it was intense that day,
but it was when the day unfolded,
it was that beautiful.
I mean the chief Sir talks about,
um, how people would be asked,
like the little guys getting scared,
people were getting too close to
the car and it was spooking him out.
So we told the police that and
they asked people, you know, folks,
can you help us out here? And they were
like, oh sure, no problem. I'll step back.
And he said, yeah, we'll take that
any other day of the week. That was,
I think that the whole city just kind
of came together and were just like, oh,
we get it. Like there was no violence,
there was no fights, there was no like,
it didn't say, I don't think
there were any arrest either.
No. Was just, everyone was just
like, we're cool to clean up. I mean,
there's other folks who'd normally
clean up after the Superbowl parade or
wherever and said, we've never had
people pick up their stuff. He goes,
well it was,
it was pretty,
it wasn't like something that you
really think was not possible. Right.
It happened that day.
Yeah. And so Dana, when you were kind
of handling the film and working,
did you work with the family at all?
Cause you had to,
cause you had to shoot a lot of footage
of like the backstory and stuff.
So how is that handling with them and,
yeah, so at first we
treaded really lightly. Um,
it's funny to think about now because I
consider them really good friends now.
And
miles is very good friends with
my son who's eight years old,
just a year older than miles
and they're really close.
They try to figure out how to video
message each other and stuff and they talk
on the phone. And so now I consider them
friends. But back when we first started,
I'm, Patricia reached out to
them first and said, you know,
we're interested in doing this
documentary. Um, and really I think a lot,
like the day we didn't, you know, we,
our plan was to get the
movie to make the movie,
but we were so rushed in making it,
I wasn't really thinking that much about
what would happen after we, you know,
we would go to a film
festival, hope to sell it. Um,
but we were so busy making the movie,
we didn't think a lot about that.
And then Warner brothers decided
to buy it. Um, and so it just,
like the day of it really blew up
more than we thought it would and go
theatrical. So I think when we
first started talking to him,
yeah,
I thought it was going to
be in the conference room
and I'm going to be showing
it to my volunteers.
Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, I was hoping it would be a
bit more than that. Um, but I, you know,
in my wildest dreams, I didn't think that,
um, what would happen, you know, happen.
Um, and so it was amazing. So
we, we, um, first reached it.
I met them at the opening day ceremony,
the miles throughout the first
pitch. Um, for the giants.
And so we met them that day and we just
kind of got them used to us. And, um,
and then a couple months later we went
to their farm and we just really hit it
off at their farm. And my
son came with us and, um,
and so he played with miles the whole
weekend and we shot them playing and,
and they're just a lovely, lovely family.
Um, and you know, by knowing them,
I understood that their intention
for this, um, to the contrary,
they didn't want to become
famous. I mean, they were there,
they're just pretty cash people.
And so the fact that this happened,
they couldn't have been a better family
for this to happen to, to have, uh,
have their wish go viral because they're
very, they're pretty chill. Um, but,
but also we had to realize that they,
they,
we weren't going to have them
do press for the documentary.
We weren't going to have them do
anything because they're not celebrities.
He's not a child actor. I remember
early on somebody said, oh,
we want to profile miles as a child
actor. I'm like, he's not a child actor.
He's a amazing cancer survivor
who had this amazing day.
Then he doesn't even know what
Twitter was or anything else.
And he doesn't know what it became.
And we want to kind of keep it that way.
And so when the film was good, it was
done. Um, I actually talked to his mom,
Natalie. I said, do
you want him to see it?
Because it really shows what the
day was. And she and I, you know,
I was kind of conflicted about that
because I wanted him to just think it
happened. Um, but she said, no, no.
She wanted him to see it and then he
wanted to see it the next day and the next
day and the next day, even though, you
know, because kids are great like that.
They can suspend disbelief
as much as they want.
And so even though they know exactly
how it happened, he knows, um,
he still loves it and still believes that
he is that kid and that Uja is Batman
and it's still very present in his,
in his life.
He beat some bad guys in Patricia's
city by city. It's just a city.
We call it that too.
I mean he thinks that the j is
the real Batman. I mean he'll say,
oh he had like he chased the real
Batman on Sunday after his wish.
The chronicle reprinted that
cover know back kid saves city.
It was on the front page of the Sunday
paper and he was walking downtown and saw
it and one of the new standards.
And so, you know, mom,
I'm available to save more lives today
if they need me on me in his mind.
And that's a beautiful segue into kind
of EMJ cause it's one of the most just,
it gives me goosebumps and it
just sacked me right in the gut.
One of the most beautiful moments
in the movie that I thought was, um,
when you guys did, when he, Jay
set up the whole acrobat thing,
the whole training thing and this kind
of like almost kind of like muscle memory
for the, for miles when I was like,
Hey, I'm going to take cause EEG.
We can describe Bj. I mean,
he is a software engineer,
a game developer and an acrobat.
And He,
so he used the showcase is all on the
field is Bruce Wayne, Bruce Wayne,
because literally Bruce Wayne and
it's so cool are the only cool,
he's like the most intimidating guy.
If he wasn't so darn nice, you know,
you're so scared of him. Then you talked
to him and he said, oh, he's nice.
He likes, this is what every human, yes.
Aspire to. That's all. Yeah, he's great.
But it was so genius at what he did was,
and what you guys did was you put miles
to this superhero training and everyone
got involved in this superhero gym
of with Dj and doing everything.
So everything that was done for the
day was also done the night before.
So miles like, oh, I guess I did this, I
get, I can do that, I can do this flip,
I can do this, crawl over.
But the, the part that got
me was the acrobat handshake.
And so it's this, this, and he did that.
And then the next day when he
went to the hotel, you know,
he's kind of scared by Batman, by
Emj. But then he does that. It's like,
and it's just like his eyes Yak. I'm
in like, I got this. Like I know,
I know this guy.
And he's like,
that footage is pretty amazing because I
did not allow any cameras when he first
met Batman Cause I thought
if he spooked wishes over,
we're going to do whatever miles wanted.
And everybody was mad at me and I said,
no, no cameras, this is
not. And they said, well,
weren't filming a documentary like that.
I never thought this was good.
I'm doing a wish and you're not going
to Mike him. And that's how it is.
So that just kind of put,
some people were pretty miffed at me,
but the wished family taped it
themselves on their iPhone or,
or would they be okay?
Yeah.
Somebody on the way out of town said
they had never had a video camera their
whole life and somebody gave it to him
as a present the night before. And um,
I know, and so on. And so they
shot, I mean I agree with you.
I think the circus center video where
the night before with some of the best,
it's the best scene in
the film that I'm in,
something nobody ever saw because
the family was only ones who had the,
had the video. And um, when they,
the circus center supposedly
shot a little of it there,
but they lost the footage.
And so the only footage that remained
was what the parents had shot.
And they did such a
heck of a job on it too.
Like usually when you get home video
from people and it's not the best,
but they did the whole scene is from their
footage and there's some really great
shots,
um,
from the day of that that I'm nick miles
dad also shot and they did an amazing,
amazing job.
We got very lucky it,
I mean it,
it,
the circuit tenor was scary because we
got a call from them and some of the
press had, we're starting
to follow the, and you know,
that's something I didn't even think
about it like when the Hyatt wanted to put
the bat man, the project, the
Batman logo on their building.
I thought that would be cool.
But that told everyone where they were
saying and then they had to have more
security.
I mean I never in my wildest dreams
thought we have to now protect this family
because now they're becoming celebrities.
And then the press was just,
some of them just playing vultures.
They,
I mean they had to find this family and
they were all trying to get some sort of
exclusive and they wanted the wanting
to see your costume the night before
they're trying to end up,
it's in my apartment. Well I pace
back and forth, try not to, you know,
pass out and
it's just, you know, something
you've never experienced.
I mean to have a news crew in our lobby
saying they didn't want to leave until
you go down there going,
it was just never happen.
So we were ill equipped
to know how to handle, um,
and obviously a really small team.
We only have 27 staff and 550 volunteers.
And so it's, you know, it
was just our little group.
And so fortunately a lot of people came
forward and started volunteering and I
would say, yes, we need your
help. Whatever you can do.
And so can we talk a little bit,
he just is like,
cause you brought him in obviously cause
you'd known him since he worked with
make a wish for a while ago.
Yup.
And so just his development
of it and bringing you in and
just kind of the who we had
a series of conferences, um,
when we were planning the wish and
saying, what about this, what about that?
Or sometimes I would see the costume is
a piece that we all worked on together
and was problematic for
us. Um, and, uh, you know,
and I knew that that was the
most important thing to mile.
So there was a lot of pressure going,
oh man,
if he gets his costume and cries when he
sees it because he was so excited about
the new costume. So it was just a
collaborative, um, amazing process.
And that I have to say, um, my,
the only gift I have is selecting
the right people, cause Eja. I mean,
these folks are brilliant and they're fun
and collaborative and they're way more
creative. And so they took
it to a level, you know,
so all that rehearsal and the dynamics
and the specifics are where the volunteer
team that were on the west.
Wow. And so how do you know Egypt? Uh, so
we worked together for a long time at, um,
at Lucasfilm, at a industrial,
had magic in, in San Francisco.
And so he was at Lucas Arts for a very,
very long time,
about 19 years or something. Um, and then
transition to Ilm for a few years now.
Now I'm a, now he runs his own
software company. Uh, but, uh, yes.
So we worked together for quite a long
time and I always just thought, man,
that guy is interesting. He was like
the most interesting person I ever,
it really is. You know,
the, that, um, that, uh,
the bearded guy that the dos Equis guy,
right. Most interesting man in the world
wife who is the Damsel in distress,
which is almost as funny.
All right. Because we just call her the
damsel because she's never in distress,
the most successful,
amazing woman of all time
gaming duo as a couple.
So a, yeah, they're just amazing
people and um, uh, you know,
I just kind of admired ejs skill at
work. He's so good at the, he does,
he like writes, you know,
machine code and stuff.
Just cause he wants to optimize
things as fast as possible.
Does that it was like, I'm going
to write it in python. Like,
cause that's not impossible. You
can do whatever. Yeah. So, um,
yeah, so he's, you know, he's
just a very, very interesting guy.
But one of the things I really liked
about him, um, at work was he, like,
some of my other closest friends are
not just a software engineer or just an
accountant or just a lawyer,
whatever it might be.
They have this kind of crazy life
outside of work where they do all these
unusual things like, you know, like
flying trapeze and ejs case. I'm or,
well eja does like 50 odd things,
but you know,
I have friends who have do this really,
really interesting volunteer thing
or like find Africa once a year and,
and doing this kind of like amazing,
like a local volunteer work that's
really needed there. And it's just,
you sort of collect this group of friends
where they're doing much more than
just their job and their,
their life,
their everyday life because that's
stressful enough as we all know. Um,
so I think that really sort of
grabbed me about Ega he was, he was a,
just such an interesting sort of global
citizen as well as being just a great
person as well and a good colleague.
So I'm, so I love that. And then they,
so they came over to a barbecue at my
place to just having this kind of random
summer barbecue. And, um,
and uh, on the way there,
I guess they were in the midst of trying
to figure out who the villains should
be and, uh, and it was Sue's idea suicide.
Mike should do it. Mike should
be, Mike should be the pain.
I'm not sure if I was the Riddler first.
And then I had,
I definitely wasn't the joker too scary,
but there they were like,
Mike should be one of the bad guys.
And uh,
so that he pitched that to me on the day
of, what are you doing? November 15th?
Just say yes.
And so I like didn't even have my phone.
I'm looking through my Google account
in my Google calendar and a well,
and a, yeah, a little plug
there for you guys. Um,
so I'm looking through my
Google calendar and, uh, and uh,
and you know, I'm, I'm like, well, yeah,
it doesn't look like I have anything on.
Sure. Um, I didn't know what I was
agreeing to and of course, neither.
Neither did he.
You know,
at that point it was 50 to 200 people
in a climbing gym or something.
And boy were we surprised
I have 30,000 people and 2 million
were alive. And it's crazy.
And what I loved about it too, he
brought in his, all this technology,
he brought him that his uh,
in gauntlet, he invented that,
which was insane arm projector projector,
which if you guys haven't seen the
film where it wasn't a density,
it's basically as aren't projector where
he was capturing or shooting off video
messages. And everything that came
through was on that. So I'm in the film,
there's kind of this funny
thing how it's like, oh,
there were some technical difficulties
and like some funny stuff like that.
But that was such a great added touch
to the entire just film to have that in
there.
I mean,
who has that? Who Invents? Excellent.
Remember your first film
festival and you said,
tell him about sitting next to curt
and the audience reaction to the,
Oh, when they were laughing. So when
we first showed the film, you know,
it's so scary to first show a film because
you've seen it while you're editing
constantly and you don't know
are people gonna like it.
It's going to work for an audience and
we're sitting showing it and people are
just cackling laughing. And I turned
to Kurt, my editor, and I was like,
I know we made a comedy, you know?
And so that was really great.
But I think one of that,
just to get back to EEG for a second,
I think one of my favorite
parts of the movie is, um,
and the day is when Ega was making
this projector and he, you know,
he could have done anything.
He could have had it on an iPhone,
which was the original
idea. Um, but he's like, oh,
then I'll be in an adult with an iPhone.
If I projected then I'm Batman.
And so the, so this was the,
what his goal was to do.
And a couple of nights before he was
pulling all nighters, making it work,
and he broke it. And he
thought, and this is like,
I think to me what the epitome of the
movie is and what of the event wise is
that, you know, he said, okay, well miles,
we'll never know that we were
going to do this cool thing.
We'll just do it on the IPAD
and it'll be fine. And he said,
but my whole life I will have known. I
could have made it even that much better.
And to me that just gives me chills that,
that's like my favorite moment in the
whole movie because I think all of these
people, the movie isn't really about a
sick kid who triumphed and had cool wish.
Um,
it has that in it.
But I think the movie is about when
these people like Uj like these guys come
together to make this amazing
thing happened just for one person.
And I think that's so,
it's just not something we see very often.
And I think that's why it
touched a nerve with people.
Even though until the movie people
didn't know really the behind the scenes,
but they knew it was special because
something that big doesn't just happen.
And so I think that, you know, even
though that moment was only for miles,
which was the whole point of the
day and nobody really knew about it,
I think people sensed that
amazing. This. Um, and so I mean,
that to me is what the [inaudible]
about what my can Patricia about and
everybody who made it happen.
Yeah. Just amazing. Um,
and we'll take some audience
questions if anyone has questions.
Nope.
Sorry.
I've used to be getting
some out of miss these spit.
Were there any issues getting the
rights for the characters and using them
okay.
With a warning about those giants?
I wasn't going there.
Yeah.
No. So the beauty of it was,
is that when it did get big,
I began to worry about that too.
Um,
fortunately I had a couple
of things on my side, um,
a search that helped me understand
that I could name him that kid,
which was not trademarked.
Huh.
Um, so I thought we were avoiding
the Batman issues, but then, um,
as it turned out at Warner brothers and
every actor who played Batman tweeted,
and then Warner brothers ended up buying
the film. And they loved it so much.
So my efforts to be worried about it,
we're ill fitted I guess.
And for me, because I knew that Warner
brothers really didn't buy documentaries,
it was just,
it wasn't even on my radar.
I just really followed the letter
of the law in terms of, um,
we just documented what was there
that day. If we were making a graphic,
it wouldn't,
it,
we made sure that it didn't have the bat
man wings and we would make it our own.
And so we went to great lengths to do
that. Um, but then in the end, you know,
maybe it wouldn't have mattered
because Warner brothers bought it,
but still it was the safer way to go. We
didn't use music that we didn't license.
You know, the, when we did the Batman
logo, it, it, it was tweaked enough.
And so in our animations and our graphics,
we made sure that it was different.
I remember the day we were sitting in
one of our followup meetings and I said,
yeah, you know, Han Zimmer composed
music for back. She's like,
what do you have his
contact info? I think so. So
yeah. So he made, we were shooting
with him, which was amazing. Yeah,
that's a great heart. He's so,
he was so gracious, you know,
all his people were like,
he only has 20 minutes.
And he was with us for like two
hours. He was so nice. And He, um,
so he did a lot of movies,
but he did the dark knight trilogy.
I'm composing and he, uh, he was playing
for us. Uh, what he played for miles.
He made a song for miles, um, which was
similar to the, to the dark night theme.
And so I sat at the end of that,
you know,
what do you think we're going to have
trouble getting that, the rights for that?
He's like, Oh, you very well
might. Here's, let me just
make something else for you.
And he just compose a song
right there on the fly.
Okay.
All right. I just did that.
Like, it was actually one of the,
like when you geek out, when you're a
filmmaker, a documentary for liquid,
that liquid wasn't in my top three of
kicking out moments. Yeah. Wow. And so,
and so one of the questions we got
from one of our viewers was, um,
so what exactly after this whole thing,
what did this do for?
Just make a wish in general.
So, um, we have the bad kid bumps, so our
referrals from the number of children, um,
who, uh, request a wish you didn't
qualify for a wish went up 46%.
Um, donations went up 25% is
I remember working out for me,
but we're so far so good keeping up. Um,
they haven't been any other requests.
A lot of people ask in the,
so there's a couple of things I'll,
I'll share that it could
be questions that come up.
Everybody asks how miles is in meiosis
great and miles is in remission and he
really thinks he saved San
Francisco that day and he'll,
he's going to second grade and he lost
his first tooth last year and he still
loves baseball and, and he's just back
on the farm. And I love that, right?
That he thinks fondly of the wishy had
the day he saved San Francisco Hollywood
ending.
Right.
That's tied up beautifully. And it's not
unsimilar to all the rest of us. Well,
Dana was working on this project.
We all went back to our lives.
We had more wishes to do. And um, so the,
the impact certainly has created
awareness, um, and a lot more people. Um,
I think what happened,
we had a wish about two months after
back kid and it was with the San Jose
Sharks and we had a child who
wanted to be a shark for the day.
The footage is on youtube. I
encourage you to see it. Um,
and they just nailed it in a way. I
mean, again, it wasn't me doing it.
All I did was make the connection and
they thought, well, what if we, so they,
before they even got to that game,
they told everybody who was coming to
the game that we have a special where,
you know, we're facilitating, we
have a VIP is, is having this wish.
And then at the arena they told him it
was the first time in the shirks history
that they allowed anyone other than one
of the players to sh to skate through
the shark's mouth.
And he signed a one day contract and in
the child lost it in front of everyone
in the arena,
fulfill that wish that night.
And the people who normally wait outside
for the players to get their autograph
weighted out for our child
wish child Sam tag lesson.
And there were so many people
that requested to buy his jersey,
the sharks now sell it in the store
and donate the proceeds to make a wish.
So some of those things,
we've had a few things to go viral that
had over 2 million hits in a week. Um,
and people just became engrossed in that
and as beautiful and sweet and we've
had a number since then. Um, so I
think that creativity piece will,
we'll continue and I think
the engagement piece and,
and we're challenged to try
to figure out how to use that.
So how do I engage people in a way that's
meaningful to a wish that is good for
the wish. Um, and then it doesn't create
a disaster for us to try to manage,
but that there are more people who want
to do good and it's nice to be able to
be a matchmaker and make those
two things happen. You can,
we'll go cause it on the line.
But this is what was your favorite moment
from the day? And I guess Dana, for you,
what was your favorite moment? Just in
creating the film and finding that voice.
Okay. Okay. All right. Ooh,
favorite part of the day. Ooh,
that's always a tough one
because there's so many. There's,
I said my answer to that once,
which is a terrible answer,
was when Eja finally tackles me at the
end of the ballpark and my portion was
done and I didn't because I was like,
I never wiped so much sweat off
my forehead in my life. But, um,
that's a terrible answer though.
So let me make up a new one.
Now that I've said that to
the entire universe, um, it
wouldn't be the first time,
I guess. Right. Um, you
know, I think for me it was,
I actually really was very excited at
the amount of people that were there. Um,
that is of course in opposition to
the goals, not just the original,
but the ultimate goals of the
event were just miles is enjoyment.
But to me it became something bigger
and bigger and bigger. And, uh,
and it became such an interesting
opportunity to sort of, um,
for San Francisco really to kind of plant
this flag in the ground and be like,
this is what's possible. Because it
was insane. None of us expected this.
And you know,
I'm sure some people wouldn't have
gotten involved if they expected it to be
this crazy and certainly not us,
we were done in any case. Um,
but,
you know,
I think it became such a big thing and
to me that meant it was going to be
visible.
And I thought that just the sheer
size of it would encourage people,
the world around to do similar kinds of
things. Um, that was important to me,
sort of in a, in a kind of the world's
changing this of this event, um,
that it could carry it forwards in
a way. Um, Chris, uh, Chris Taylor,
a great a friend from Mashable,
he posted one of the first articles
to go viral about the event and he's
featured in the movie as well,
and he's really, really great.
But about a week after
the movie, he said, uh,
certain movie a week after a week after
the day he posted something on Mashable.
It's a bat could date back. Kid
was beautiful, let's keep it going.
And so that was a very interesting
kind of call to action I thought.
And to me was one of the larger
goals of being involved. I,
I think a week or so after that I kind
of compiled my crazy like stress addled
brain into a big long blog post,
which became my longest ever read or my,
my most ever read a post on
my, on my, um, on my blog,
spot out my blogger
account. Thank you. Google.
No, seriously. Like, it's like,
it's like my entire life. Um, so,
you know, it became like the most
visible thing I've ever posted.
And so that was another
way of I think playing up,
sort of paying it forwards and taking
the day that happened magically and kind
of turning it into a message.
And,
and that's another reason why
I just sort of jumped into, uh,
when I heard about the movie happening,
I was so excited about it. And, um,
Dan who was so passionate came with the
exact same spirit that we had of giving
and of just really being
really keen to get the,
get the message right and, um, to
do the best possible job we could,
um, with such an important idea.
And so, so I think, anyway,
long story short, um, I think actually
the visibility turned out to be very,
very important,
I think,
and has led to this documentary and has
led to then Warner brothers buying it.
It's crazy. Um, lots of people
seeing it and, and people,
the real practical realities of people
emailing me and saying really loved the
movie, decided to do volunteering
and, um, my own state, my own country.
I had a friend from Germany say,
I couldn't believe you did that thing.
That was crazy.
It looks like so much fun.
I've been meaning to volunteer
for a long time. I never did it.
And I signed up last week after
seeing the movie. It was like, Oh yes,
that's the goal. That's the goal. Yeah.
So for me, I'm a few, but I
think that the day of, um,
it was time we had a bus
that followed the, the, um,
the two Lamborghini's and,
um,
it was further wished family and a few
folks embedded for the Twitter account
and all the wish family.
And,
and so there were a few
moments when the bus, yeah,
we'd cheer and then there would be a hush
of silence where we were all so moved.
And you know, the first time that morning
happened when we took our website down,
um, a few minutes after the
wish started and I thought,
am I supposed to be excited? We took the
website. I guess that's a good thing. Wow.
And then, um, when the president tweeted
and then the White House and first lady,
and um, there were moments
where it was the cheering,
but then you realize you
started to use the magnitude.
And in fact on the bus I sorted, you
know, Jimmy Kimmel or something, I dunno,
we started getting offers already and
I began thinking about that going,
this isn't, you know, when this
over. And um, but the moment,
the most poignant moment
was after the last caper,
it was at the ballpark and seeing miles
so happened he ran the bases and it was
like, yes, he was Batman for the day.
We did that and everybody else happy.
And San Francisco amazing.
And so all of that was sinking
in as that had finished,
everybody was safe.
And I'm watching this,
we're on the bus and we didn't tell anyone
what route we were taking between the
ballpark in civic center. Right. We
didn't dictate that wasn't public.
I didn't tell them which route to take,
but it became an impromptu parade route.
And so sitting on a bus and just watching
construction workers come off of their
site just to wave at us.
I couldn't believe it.
And I began to lose it and just close
to openly sobbing and then remembered I
had to give a speech to 25.
It's a big center and not freak
out about that. Um, but the,
the energy from the crowd
was so loving and so joyful.
And Comcast sports net,
I have to give one shout
out to them because when I
asked them to do me a favor,
they follow their crew, followed
us around, taped each Kapor,
came back and edit it on the fly and
then played it that day in civic center.
Cause I said have something,
all of this was true.
They donated a $30,000
satellite truck that day,
so all the other stations could pull
that video without a watermark and donate
it. I mean they were
amazing and pulled that off.
And so I had no idea what we are going to
see when we got up to the civic center.
Right. And so, but I had my outtakes
and we had coordinated and I'd say,
let's take a look. And they played
the footage. It was unbelievable.
So that's incredible.
A lot of goodness happened that day
in day was just a beautiful film.
So just kind of what, what was your
favorite moment that you discovered?
Um, and my favorite moment of
the film was, like I said before,
when I'm broke his projector and that
was my favorite moment of the film.
But I think,
um,
my favorite part in the whole making of
it was my goal was to let the spirit of
the day live on cars for everybody like
me who missed, who missed the actual day.
And so I'm, I'm really, when
I hear stories like that,
what Mike said about his friend,
or when I have people email me about that,
it made them go out and want to volunteer
and be a part of a community and,
and get out of their shell for a while.
That makes me really happy and proud. Um,
and,
but I think for me,
I'm meeting these and
everybody involved in the day,
and then the crew that I was so fortunate
to assemble for backup for the movie,
um, those, the cast and the crew
of this film are really dear.
And you feel like now you could take
that group along with you to the,
to the rest of your life,
both professionally and
just as friends. And, um,
to me that's a real gift.
Um,
that and that actually somebody I
used to work with as it is here in the
audience. And I mean, that's a
good thing. We worked on our,
on my first film together.
And so I think it's that,
it's like you have the fortunate thing
as a documentary filmmaker to be able to
go out there and meet
amazing people whose nobody,
not just a humdrum person would be worthy
to be in a documentary. Right? Right.
And so you have these,
these people that you come in contact
with and then you get to carry them with
you, hopefully forever.
And so I think that's, um,
and this group was an amazing addition
to all, to all of those people.
Well, to give you your sentence, literally
everyone in the project is that lovely,
doesn't seek the limelight, was just doing
a great thing and Dana's no different.
She volunteered.
None of the people who worked on the film
thought it was going to be a big film.
They all did it for next to nothing or
bare minimum just do it to cover expenses
and, and Dana included and
you know, ironically she
likes to joke that, you know,
the first documentary that really reached
some level of commercial success and
it was purchased by Warner Brothers is,
is a donation.
So she's contributed at
all to the back kid fun,
which benefits San Francisco charities,
including make-a-wish. So, um,
that's the level of,
you know,
altruistic and generosity
of everyone on the project.
Well, I think that was an incredible thing
that no one was really in this for the
money. No, it was all about
miles and it was all about just,
just capturing that day for him and stuff.
And even two years later,
I mean this is, this is
really, it's incredible that
people are still caring and,
and wanting this, just that kind
of impact that it had on, you know,
social media and just in,
in culture.
It's a cultural phenomenon and
people are studying this as like,
how did this happen? Why did this
and how did this work? And it just,
it's one of those just perfect storm.
So, um, so just really quickly,
can you talk about a little bit how people
can get involved with, make a wish or,
um, just kind of want,
make a wish is doing okay.
Locally, SF wish.org. Um, I
have a board of directors.
I have two young professional boards.
I have one here in Silicon Valley.
I have a youth board,
um, for kids, 12 to 18,
about half of them are former wish
kids who get back. Um, so, uh,
there's obviously we have events. We
just did a, a walk here on cocoa campus.
Um, so there's lots of ways to
get involved in fundraising.
We're one of the few charities that
takes airline mile donations. Um,
and we use those for the wishes itself.
So that's pretty cool and a great way
if you want to donate airline miles. Um,
and for everyone else, go to
[inaudible] dot org and, um,
and that will lead you to our
international affiliates as well,
and hopefully engage you in and hopefully
change your life forever and transform
it in a way that you can't imagine.
Well, that's great. So thank you
guys so much for being here. Um,
back kid begins a is available
digitally, uh, September 25th and on DVD,
October six. So thank you guys.
Thank you. Thank you. Yep.
Okay.